bonjour à tous
je suis un peu désolé d'arrivée puis de
plomber l'ambiance peut-être pour
commencer mais savez-vous que canada est
à peu près 800 dix mille personnes qui
sont atteints d'un cancer encore de 600
mille patients pour cause d'insuffisance
cardiaque
chaque année il ya cinquante mille
nouveaux coeurs pour des traitements en
insuffisance cardiaque
imaginez que il ya un mort par 17
minutes pour chaque cancer
c'est vraiment une question pour tout le
monde
tout le monde se sent concerné votre
voisin peut avoir un 15 heures demain je
pense que certains d'entre vous l'ont
déjà vécu
pour ceux qui sont déjà allés aussi à
l'hôpital pour de pas forcément des
problèmes aussi conséquents mais curieux
au moins un parcours chirurgicale on se
rend compte que c'est pas évident c'est
assez chaotique en fait vous arrivez en
tant que patient vous allez rencontrer
un médecin peut-être un chirurgien
dépendamment du problème vous allez lui
expliquer ce qui vous tracasse la
douleur que vous pouvez avoir des
sensations de masse à certains endroits
et il va avoir besoin de faire des
examens complémentaires
bien souvent on voit utiliser l'imagerie
j'imagine que tout le monde voit à peu
près ce qu'est une radiographie
ça c'est du 2d l'image ici ça va
permettre d'avoir une représentation en
3d qu'en fait vous avez vous êtes
admettons patients on va vous coucher
sur le lit vous allez rentrer dans un
tube
c'est ce tube qui veut générer des
rayons x et qui va
en fait avoir un sortie est d'image
empilées le problème avec ces images là
c'est que le médecin n'est pas l'expert
pour les lire donc il a besoin d'une
autre personne qui est le radiologue et
qui va aller évaluer chacune des images
et essayer de trouver en fait la cause
du problème
cette discussion là elle peut être
génératrice de problèmes pourquoi parce
que les deux personnes n'ont pas
forcément le même langage ils n'ont pas
le même niveau d'expertisé ils sont pas
concentrés sur la même chose d'appris
avoir une perte d'informations mais il
ya possibilité la clé un petit décalage
entre les deux discours l'autre problème
ici c'est que bon vous avez des
radiologues mais peut-être pas c'est pas
suffisamment je pense que tout le monde
a entendu plus ou moins parler de
l'espèce de bouchons de queues
interminables pour avoir des irm par
exemple c'est tout à fait typique
le dernier problème ici c'est que quand
les ct scan sont apparus il ya une
vingtaine d'années à peu près on parlait
de 80 tranchant 80 images empilés
imaginer que le radiologue voit ses 80
images là aujourd'hui on est quasiment à
800 images ça décuple facilement le
temps de traitement
une fois que le diagnostic donc aura été
établi avec l'aide du radiologue le
médecin va retourner voir son patient et
va lui expliquer maintenant mettez vous
dans la condition là vous avez
possiblement un cancer vous n'êtes pas
forcément très ouverts vous être un
petit peu inquiet vous vous n'avez pas
non plus les expertises pour comprendre
tout ce que le médecin va vous dire elle
vous vraiment capable d'imaginer la
suite de votre vie commence
et devoir être opéré qu'est ce que vous
allez vivre exactement dans les mois
suivants on rencontre donc ici un
deuxième problème dans ce parcours là
une fois le diagnostic posé le médecin
va faire la préparation opératoire alors
quand on parle de préparation opératoire
on va reprendre les images 2d on va voir
où est le problème à opérer qu'elle
abhorre on va utiliser pour faire la
chirurgie et que c'est vraiment toute la
préparation
ici encore même problème qu'avec
l'imagerie michel mince et en 2d
êtes vous vraiment capable de dévaluer
un concept en 3d avec des images 2d très
très difficile l'autre problème ici
c'est que on
une fois choisi la chirurgie
généralement il va y avoir un espace
d'entraînement pour s'assurer que tous
fils bien ici aussi c'est difficile
d'imaginer on a les seuls outils que le
chirurgien assez concrètement des
représentations très idéalisée
imaginez on veut faire une opération
d'une tumeur au cerveau ok vous allez
tester ça peut-être sur un vrai bon
après ça roule mais un cerveau normal
pas malade pas représentatif de ce que
vous devez effectivement opéré le
dernier problème ici avec le parcours
chirurgicales actuelles c'est bien
souvent à l'opération même autre exemple
qu'une tumeur changer un petit peu vous
avez un problème vasculaire on va
essayer de vous faire rentrer un
cathéter dans un des vaisseaux et
le comment l'opération en fait on
consiste à se guider par imagerie donc
par rayons x
le fait d'envoyer des doses d'accord on
va connaître la position de l'instrument
précisément et oui ça va guider et oui
on va aller vraiment dans du détail mais
possiblement main d'ici 10-15 ans on est
à risque d'avoir un autre problème
un autre cancer parce que ces rayons x
là sont dangereux pour la santé fait
finalement du bloc ou plutôt dans le
sens de la salle d'attentes au bloc
opératoire on a quatre gros set up où on
note vraiment des problèmes
ces étapes là sur lesquels nous nous
sommes concentrés et où nous vous
proposons des nouvelles approches pas
pour tous remplacés mais plutôt pour
donner une assistance pour aider le
chirurgien est aussi le patient dans son
cursus pour se soigner
et si enfin on commence avec le
diagnostic professionnel je relate est
ici un petit peu les 3 limite que j'ai
énoncé il y à la question de l'expertisé
du médecin la disponibilité des
radiologues et la durée danalyse comment
faire pour répondre à ces limites là la
première solution est d'aller avec de la
modélisation 3d alors c'est apparu c'est
de plus en plus en retours cliniques
actuellement le travail maintenant en
réalité consiste à améliorer la
modélisation 3d à partir des images 2d a
accéléré le la génération comment ça
marche
à la sortie d'un sept escales dont vous
avez les trois images qui vont être
arrêtées juste des road gris chacun des
niveaux de gris représente une structure
anatomique spécifiques
c'est à dire que si vous allez avoir du
blanc va ça va représenter pour un ct
scan des eaux de cette façon là vous
allez être capable de différents sites
distingués vraiment les organes de la
tumeur par exemple ou de tout autre
problème ici est ce que vous voyez là
grosse masse milieu en été c'est un
anévrisme donc on voit concrètement que
le vaisseau est complètement étendue
en large et à un endroit et le problème
opéré est ici la deuxième solution qu'on
propose c'est l'impression 3d ça c'est
nettement moins utilisés actuellement
bien que ça commence petit à petit
concrètement comment ça marche
on va utiliser de la poudre donc pour
créer le modèle puis lorsque vous voyez
c'est une un modèle en fait de la
mâchoire inférieure
ça c'est une méthode à poudre il existe
une autre technologie qui consiste à
avoir un fils de plastique qu'on chauffe
et qu'on va entasser fait que ces deux
techniques
celle ci est plus intéressante au niveau
médical car elle est beaucoup beaucoup
plus précise que que l'autre en fait qui
a un fils plastique assez épais une fois
que vous avez imprimés donc ici on a la
mâchoire inférieure et supérieure est ce
que vous voyez l'énorme masse en réalité
ça c'est une tumeur
vous imaginez la personne en fait elle a
une espèce de grosse boursouflures à ce
niveau là la concrètement on est capable
de se rendre compte ok c'est
effectivement à cet endroit là qu'il
faut opérer qu'il faut enlever le gros
intérêt c'est que sur l'image de droite
vous voyez en fait toutes les tout
l'impression 3d et trancher vous allez
pouvoir voir vraiment à l'intérieur de
la tumeur ou est ce qu'elle est qu'est
ce que vous pouvez imaginer comme
approche est exactement fait qu'elle est
le diagnostic
on en vient maintenant à l'éducation du
patient
le patient dont je vous disais il n'est
pas expert il est inquiet comment est ce
qu'on est capable de lui expliquer son
problème ici aussi on peut utiliser
l'impression 3d
vous imaginez très bien que si vous
montrez
la mâchoire précédente à votre patient
il va mieux conceptualiser comprendre
que si vous lui montrer des images en
niveaux de gris ou bien même le modèle
3d autre exemple que la mâchoire ici on
a un cas très très importante de
déformations de la colonne mais ok
pourquoi est ce que le patient un mal
pourquoi est ce qu'il est pas capable de
bouger vous allez avoir quelque chose à
l'appui pour lui expliquer ce qui va
être capable de faire ce qu'on peut lui
proposer comme soutien comme la
physiothérapie peut aider comment est ce
que en fait d'une prise en charge
globale va pouvoir être faite en
s'appuyant sur le modèle 3d concrets au
niveau de l'après opération donc la
troisième étape la principale limite
c'est la limite de réalisme je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure pour préparer
l'opération certes on utilise les images
2d mais surtout on va tester par exemple
vous imaginez il faut remplacer une
partie d'un ace on va mettre une
prothèse
on va prendre un peu l'offre
correspondant à votre patient on va
prendre un os très souvent qui va être
idéalisé ou qui va représenter dans une
certaine mesure le problème que vous
allez opéré il ya toujours un décalage
est ce que la représentation idéalisée
et suffisante pour effectivement pouvoir
après opéré le patient et s'entraîner
effectivement ici on propose trois
solutions l'impression 3d je pense que
ça peu près clair pour tout le monde
depuis le début au fur et à mesure la
deuxième solution
excusez moi
exemple très concret l'intérêt de
l'impression 3d pour le bloc pour la
préparation opératoire c'est qu'on va
avoir une sensation réelle un touché
réel certes c'est important par exemple
d'avoir une vraie forme mais le
chirurgien il a besoin de savoir de
comprendre quand il touche et c'est bien
plus important que de simplement le voir
donc avoir des matériaux qui représente
qui reproduisent en quelque sorte le les
structures en termes de propriétés
mécaniques
c'est quelque chose de très important et
dont ils sont très friands
ici on reprend aussi la mâchoire en fait
que je vous ai montré pour l'impression
3d avant et c'est une fête c'est un test
de pose d'implants dentaires
on a failli décidé de mettre l'image en
parallèle qui représentait la vraie
opération vous à épargner un peu c'était
un peu trop sanguinolent mais
concrètement c'est exactement les mêmes
sensations le même rendu et du coup la
préparation elle prend toute sa mesure
c'est réel l'autre les deux autres
solutions font appel un peu de réalité
virtuelle réalité augmentée j'imagine
que la plupart d'entre vous on a entendu
parler qu'est ce que c'est
l'arrêté virtuel versus la réalité mixte
ait virtuel imaginez vous avez un casque
sur les yeux vous ne voyez plus votre
environnement et on vous met dans un
environnement complètement virtuel on va
donc être capable de produire en fait
une scène totale dans le club a en fait
on va pouvoir s'entraîner imaginez
vous allez faire par exemple on veut
enlever une appendicite
ok on va représenter les outils on va
donner aux chirurgiens en fait les
outils on va lui mettre un casque et il
va être capable de devoir d'avoir un
retour haptique donc de sentir la même
façon qu'avec l'impression 3d les
différents organes et par genre à quel
moment il faudrait qu'il s'arrête la
réalité mixte
al'inverse sais que vous allez garder
l'environnement autour de vous imaginez
vous êtes ici que vous allez continuer à
avoir de nos voisins vous moi peut-être
vous regardez le tout ce qui va les voir
autour de vous mais vous allez avoir en
plus un hologramme devant vous qui va
représenter par exemple le regarde en
question mais je n'ai vous faites une
opération cardiaque ok vous avez le
coeur vous êtes capable de tourner
autour vous êtes capable de l'agrandir
de couper ok comment est-ce que le coeur
à l'intérieur il est à ce qu'il n'y
aurait pas un problème qu'on aurait par
hasard manqué sur les images le déçoit
aussi c'est possible avec ces trois
solutions non en fait sont vraiment des
êtres très importante pour le chirurgien
d'une part pour comprendre mais aussi
pour s'entraîner on en arrive à la
chirurgie la chirurgie j'ai commencé en
plombe un peu l'ambiance je vais
peut-être vous faire peur maintenant
imaginez mesdames que vous avez une
tumeur
du sein l'opération concrètement
consiste à quasiment asseoir la patiente
en réalité et on voit possiblement
indépendamment des coffres une résection
ma mère donc on va essayer d'enlever le
lever le symbole veut au moins la tumeur
dans le sein le problème ici certes vous
avez l'imagerie préopératoire pour
savoir ce que vous devez enlever mais
comment est-ce que vous êtes capable
avec un organe mou donc qui bouge selon
les positions de savoir où est-ce que
vous bien effectivement opéré mais
actuellement c'est vraiment un problème
on le faut juger on va ouvrir qui bat on
va se rendre compte ok ben là il
finalement il faut enlever plus que ce
qui a été enlevée plus moins ou un autre
endroit
donc il ya possibilité d'enlever plus
possiblement même de deux zones non
problématique
puis on s'entend au risque d'amener
d'autres problèmes par la suite aux
patients donc la question c'est comment
est ce qu'on est capable de localiser
des organes centraux de problème et avec
une précision relative seront proposés
si donc c'est l'art et le d'augmenter
suis je vous réfère la slide précédentes
la réalité augmentée on voit encore le
patient donc l'idée ici c'est de
s'arranger pour faire un recalage en
réalité de lauriane sur le patient qui
va être couchés devant devant le
chirurgien au bloc opératoire
j'ai ici deux vidéos la première
représente un coeur en réaliser donc
simplement un seul organe
bon je passe le coeur normalement donc
vous imaginez imaginez un seul organe le
patient couchez vous voyez le coeur en
été c'est la même chose que ce que vous
voyez ici un autre niveau
parce qu'ici on est capable de recaler
complètement le squelette sur le patient
qui est couché
donc voilà enlevez tous les os le reste
les vaisseaux machin vous y voyez le
coeur aux bons endroits normalement
ceci ça va être très très utile aussi si
pour une opération par exemple j'en
reprends l'exemple du vasculaire vous
avez besoin de savoir exactement la
position ce qu'on utilise donc c'est les
rayons x pendant l'opération
peut-être qu'au début vous avez pas
besoin d'avoir une précision absolue
faisait pas forcément besoin d'un rayon
x qui va vous dire ok aux deux minimes
et milliman vous êtes à cet endroit là
lisez ici savez utiliser la réalité mix
dans les premières phases de l'opération
pour placer correctement l'intervention
précisent qui a besoin effectivement de
doses de rayons x pour visualiser
l'instrument dans le corps mais au moins
si on gagne je sais pas moi 5 minutes 10
minutes
mais imaginez toute la dose qu'on
diminue et possiblement mince sap et
éviter le cancer à la personne d'ici une
dizaine d'années et maintenant je vous
dis et si c'est pas si improbable
aujourd'hui on a fait une fin
aujourd'hui dans les précédentes
semaines on a fait 1 on a eu affaire à
un cas où on a pu mettre en place
utiliser ces différentes technologies là
bon vous voyez si c'est à peu près le
coeur d'un crâne merci que je vois ici
vous l'avez en impression 3d donc on a
fait à partir de ces imagerie 2d la
modélisation 3d comme vous voyez et on
l'a fait imprimer le chirurgien à
utiliser ceci pour expliquer aux
patients déjà le problème le problème
étant à ce niveau là vous voyez le
cercle rouge et ce qu'on voit en réalité
c'est ici il ya un trou en réalité se
trouve la contient une tumeur le but
était d'enlever cette tumeur
et en quelque sorte de s'assurer que ben
on arrive à peu près à préparer ce qu'il
a été possible de faire du coup c'est
que on a pu ici donc ça c'est celle à
l'est comme la vraie le vrai crâne du
patient
le chirurgien a simulé dans par
ordinateur la coupe qu'il allait faire
pendant l'opération et il a fait
imprimer exactement le volume
correspondant à cette coupe mais au
moyen d'un matériau qui va être vieux
con tu paies tible ce matériel à une
fois le même trop réalisé pendant
l'opération on a été l'un serré de 2
dans la réalité ça complètement
reboucher la portion où il y avait la
tumeur de cette façon là vous êtes
capable de vraiment à voir l'espèce de
rendu ou une opération complète du
patient de la salle d'attentes avec
l'explication que monsieur vous avez
ceci vous voyez où est ce qu'il ya un
problème on va vous l'indre vous allez
avoir un trou mais on va être capable de
le remplacer
et au final marine on va pu voir que
peut-être vous avez été opérée que vous
avez un problème
c'est vraiment l'espoir que les
chirurgiens et que les patients je pense
ont de plus en plus je remercie beaucoup
[Applaudissements]